hey everyone this is ravi from simply
learn
welcome to this facebook ads full course
video for 2021.
in this full course we will be covering
topics like
what and how facebook ads work the
various kinds of facebook ads
how the facebook algorithm works
facebook shop
and live streaming and how it compares
with instagram
will also tell you some tips and
strategies of how to make the most of
the platform
for this video we have our experts rob
and rahul
taking us through all the topics so
without further ado
let's start by talking about facebook
ads before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn
in a world where a lot of competing
different products
satisfy the same requirement you have a
lot of advertisers who want you to try
their product
and then you have other advertisers who
want you to try their product
try my product try my product
try my product try note try my
product my products the best no no no no
my product's the best try my product
well
i want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product
well there's only one way you can prove
your product is better than the rest
and that's with powerful advertising and
one of the best ways to advertise on the
internet
is via social media and through the
largest social media platform in the
world and that's
facebook so today we're going to talk
about
facebook ads tutorial and i'm excited to
teach this class
my name is rob sanders i'm with simply
learn and today we are going to talk
about
all the different ads that facebook has
to offer
so introduced back in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean
that means there's a lot of advertisers
why is there a lot of advertisers
because a lot of people
use facebook it's a popular platform so
not only is it popular but it's popular
with advertisers because
if you're advertising on facebook you
have the opportunity
to share your product and your brand
with users who you think are going to
buy your product or associate with your
brand and on facebook you can do that a
number of different ways
specifically in somebody's news feed and
specifically
that person's news feed that again is
interested
potentially interested in your brand
your product
so there's a lot of ways to advertise
and a lot of reasons why you want to
advertise so i just mentioned one of the
reasons hey it's an
opportunity for you to reach out to
people who
are targeted who are specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with
the amount of time that people spend on
facebook okay people spend
a lot of time on facebook in fact not
only do people spend a lot of time on
facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27
billion in the third quarter of 2018
and so when we say spend a lot of time
we mean
going to that facebook profile at least
once a day
okay so a lot of eyeballs throughout the
day
checking their news feed on facebook
facebook also
enables you the advertiser to find the
perfect audience
and so that's the great combination a
lot of people on facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people
based on specific interest
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive
and pro about facebook is it's lesser
spend greater reach and what do we mean
by that well
traditionally facebook is a little bit
cheaper
than other online advertising models it
is definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional
advertising models and facebook has been
known to have
good return on investment because it's
cost a little bit less than
other advertising models and other
advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook
so if you're into building a brand
you want to be on facebook why because
it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you
allow users to know what your brand is
all about because remember
you're putting your brand in front of
like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your
your advertisement in somebody's news
feed it's going to add value
it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if
that person's friend is associated with
that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody
who is on facebook active on facebook
and is your targeted demographic
and the great thing about facebook is it
also has other features other
advertising features such as retargeting
so you could target people who've
already expressed an interest in your
service or product but if they didn't go
through the conversion process meaning
they didn't go all the way through
and and buy your product you can
certainly reach out to them again
just like your traditional retargeting
options on
say google or some other advertising
platform facebook works the same way
we want to be able to reach out to
people who aren't fully committed at
that point in time
but we can reach out to them at another
point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great
feature that we could take advantage of
that we'll talk about more throughout
this session
and then it helps increase revenue sales
and leads and
and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after
you know more revenue more sales more
leads
so facebook allows us to educate our
audience
again a targeted audience about a
specific product we have to offer so the
more
our audience knows about our product
especially if their friends and family
members and colleagues are using the
product then the more likely they're
going to purchase
so if you go back to the other feature
higher revenue less spend this is the
primary reason
because you have a chance to influence
somebody who's very targeted
who's very active on the platform and
who may have like-minded people in their
life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination
and so today we're going to talk about
all the different types of facebook ads
and we're going to start out with the
single image ad
and the single image ad are just single
image advertisements that have an
optional text on top and a link
description that links to the website
so single image ads are probably the
most popular
you can see them on probably your own
facebook feed if you look so in fact
i'll just jump over to my facebook feed
right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here
and it's from shopify partners so become
a shopify partner
at e-commerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify
must be you know a brand that is
trying to woo my business okay so they
know
that somebody that i'm associated with
or maybe i fit their demographic
so they're targeting my news feed with a
single image ad
so that's what a single image ad looks
like it's simply just
one single image with some description
and the great thing about this single
image if you haven't noticed
is the pixels are pretty large it's 1200
by 628 so it kind of stands out a little
bit
it's not your traditional thumbnail it
really pops when you look at the news
feed
so again if i go back to my news feed
here you can see it just really stands
out within the news feed
so i can't miss it if i'm a targeted
part of their targeted audience it's
hard for me
to you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially
again if i know somebody in
my network on facebook or either that be
a friend or family member is associated
with that product
okay in addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you
in in carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action
and so here you can see simply learn has
a
example of a carousel ad where they're
showcasing
their different courses so this allows
users to view
a range of all your different products
and services
if you have multiple products and
services to offer then the
carousel ads would be a good option for
you
so in addition to the carousel ads and
single image ads
it gets a little bit more sophisticated
in terms of technology where
facebook allows us to offer up video ads
and so video ads
are interactive it's a good way to
really
showcase your product your brand your
service
and the great thing about the video ads
is they can
go from just a few seconds all the way
up to you know two minutes
or excuse me all the way up to 120
minutes and so
you can really really put a lot of time
and effort into the video ads to really
put your brand out there
and so the one thing about video is it
is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads
so the video ads are really a popular
way for you as an advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there
and not just a few seconds but you know
really tell a nice complete story
to get the engagement to get the person
to
take the action you want them to do so
that's why video ads have become very
popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your carousel ad
so facebook also allows us to
advertise something called lead ads and
what lead ads allow us to do is obtain
user details okay so we can acquire or
get
an email address or phone number from
somebody who's interested in our product
or service
and that person doesn't even have to
leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad
somebody clicks on sign up and they get
this form submission and the great thing
about
the lead ad is that it can sync up
with any crm or most of your popular
crms i should say for example
salesforce is a good example of a crm
where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate
you know leads for your business and the
forum itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform
another form of advertising on facebook
are slideshows okay so unlike the
carousel ads which rotate
and the carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery
so it allows you to really put your best
images out there
with a really strong call to action just
like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing
you know their different classes and
then they have they get started today
call to action to really punctuate the
slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here
by showing different different images
and then
the last type of ad on facebook is
called the collection ad
and so these ads combine basically your
video
your slideshow or your product images
taken from your product catalog
okay so if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you could see
the simply learn example here they're
showing
you know not only you know some some
good slide shows and imagery
with some good messaging below that so
before we get into the steps for
creating an ad on facebook
let's talk about some of the important
changes that
have happened on facebook recently in
light of
data sharing so really what facebook's
done
is they've made an important change on
how user data
is being used for advertising and so
what facebook's
done is they removed something called a
partner category
and that was an ad targeting program
which the targeting
option was based on data provided by a
third-party partner
so if you're an advertiser you had a
third party partner that provided some
targeted options to you
that was known as a partner category and
in summary facebook has removed that
program and so now the only way you can
gain user information
is if they provide that voluntary like
the lead ad for example
now you have to get the data directly
from the third party now
so you can't have that third party give
you that targeting
option anymore you can certainly again
capture the data yourself
by relying on leak capture landing pages
as an example or the lead ads and you
can certainly still outsource your
advertising to lead gen
agencies and media buying companies okay
but the partner category has more or
less
gone away okay so now let's get into
how to create a facebook app so what are
the steps
so the first thing you'll have to do is
set up a campaign
so when you're setting up a campaign you
have to select
what kind of spending you want to do for
your advertisement
and what you want to achieve okay so you
have to in other words identify the goal
okay so with facebook you have two
opportunities at hand here
you can jump into an auction just like
google what you're going to do
is your ads going to enter into an
auction and so
this is where you can decide how you
want to spend your money to achieve your
goals by choosing
an appropriate bid strategy for the
auction so
in the auction you're competing with
other advertisers
another option is you could do reach and
frequency and so with region
frequency you'll be able to advertise to
your brand's audience
with a fixed cost so reach and frequency
allows you as the advertiser
to better predict the delivery cost
and reach of your branding campaigns so
with auction
you have more choice you have
flexibility of scalability but
not a lot of predictability okay because
again
you're going into an auction and your
auction is going to be competing against
other advertisers so
it's this option is available to all
advertisers
and you can have pricing that you can
change during the auction price
process so that's the unpredictability
part
is the pricing so pricing can fluctuate
during the auction because you have
different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad
with reach and frequency you'll be able
to
plan and set up your campaigns and
actually set it up so it's more
predictable on
how the delivery is going to be done
with
reach and frequency so more
predictability when reaching frequency
because you could set everything up
in your campaign okay so again with the
reach and frequency you'll be able to
advertise with a fixed cost auction
you're not necessarily going with a
fixed cost you're going more scalability
flexibility on cost
that can change okay so once you choose
your objective for your advertisement
then you need to choose the type of
advertisement
you want to do and it's based on your
objectives
so what's your objective is it awareness
to drive awareness is it to drive
consideration
or is it to drive a conversion so these
are the three
objectives available to you for your
advertising you want to choose one of
those objectives
so let's take a look at each of these
objectives available to you
okay so let's start out with awareness
so awareness can help
with creating an interest for your
product
or or your service so when we say
awareness we're thinking maybe brand
awareness
or product awareness to get out there
in front of people okay so with
consideration
it's a little bit different than
awareness but not so different in that
we're really aiming to get people to
think
more about our product and service and
have them take the next step so with
awareness you're introducing your
product and service
with consideration you're getting people
to take the next step
and start looking for information about
the product or service
you're advertising and then conversion
is
kind of that final step if you're really
after conversion
you really want that person
to make the decision okay so they're
either going to buy
or use your product or service okay and
so that's the conversion objective
so you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion
and so let's go back to awareness okay
so
if we look at awareness under awareness
we have brand awareness
and we have reach okay so we look at
brand awareness really what we're trying
to do
is we're trying to increase awareness
about
our brand or the product in our brand so
these types of objectives i mean
meaning awareness don't really emphasize
interaction okay you're not
really trying to get somebody to
purchase or
or buy something or opt into a
newsletter
really your goal as an advertiser with
brand awareness
is to get your product out there so
people are aware that it exists
okay let alone forget about buying it or
opting into a newsletter
you really your goal with awareness and
brand awareness
is to get people to see that you're
existing
your product exists your service exists
it's available and really
the aim is to create high brand recall
amongst
users rather than focusing on generating
revenue so
when we say you know high brand recall
what we mean
is hey if your brand is out there and
you
are really pushing it out there amongst
a large
targeted demographic audience then the
next time that audience sees your brand
they're going to be able to associate
with it
it's not going to be foreign to them or
the first time they've ever
seen it you really want them to recall
hey i know that brand i've seen that
brand before okay that's kind of the
reaction you want to get from a brand
awareness hey that's a cool looking logo
or
man that product looked interesting now
i'm going to take the next step
so that's what brand awareness really
needs to do it needs to create that
recall
for that for your audience okay so let's
take a look now at reach
so with reach reach ensures that our
advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget
so with reach we're really trying to
reach
or get our ad out there to as many
people as possible
given who we're trying to target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend
so it helps to target a smaller audience
to visit your website
watch your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's
with reach we're just really trying to
get it out there okay so
let's move on to consideration so we
talked about awareness we talked about
brand awareness and
reach with consideration we have
you know people who are willing to take
that next step okay so if we're
targeting a specific demographic and
we're looking at consideration we really
want them to
do something with our ad we don't want
them just to recall it
or see it for the first time we want
them to take that next step
and so with consideration we have
traffic so if we have an ad
you know the least we want somebody to
do who's seen our brand before
is at least click on our ad okay so we
want people to
you know click on our ad and go to our
website
really that's a goal of consideration
is hey i know that brand i've seen that
brand before let me click on this
and see what they have to offer so this
might involve
them listening to a podcast or reading
an article
or being introduced to an app so really
you're setting the stage for
further down the funnel by further
introducing them to something that's on
your website so you really want them to
take that next
baby step the next baby step is clicking
on the ad going to your site
and further educating themselves about
your particular product or service so
facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience
based on their past behavior okay so
that's a great thing about facebook it's
you can really really get targeted here
with your audience
okay so engagement so we talk about
traffic we're gonna talk about
engagement so
these types of ads are useful when we
want users to engage
more with our ad for example we can
you know really have an advertisement or
post
that will allow people to like it they
can respond
or even take advantage of an offer so
that's what we mean by engagement we
really want people to react
positively within facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement
an engagement audience for your facebook
page that can be used for future
advertising campaigns
so we're really getting people to take
that next step
and what's that next step if they don't
go to our website they can like
what we have to say and then we can have
app installs so that's another option to
us for consideration so app installs are
great
if we want to send users to an app store
for example
so they can download our app so if we're
really really pushing an
app that we just developed then an app
installed could be a good opportunity
under consideration to allow that user
to take the next step
and download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app
we have video views so video views are
are good advertisements when you're
promoting
your product or service and you really
want a high number of views so remember
early on we were talking about the types
of ads available on facebook we talked
about video views how they get 10 to 30
percent
more engagement well that's really
what we want videos to do under
consideration we really want people to
understand what we're trying to do and
really
engage with our product and so they
could turn around and like it
they could turn around and um push it
out to their friends
so video we know is high engaging with
an audience
and so having a video allows you to
really
allow that video to potentially go viral
okay so video views help users engage
and enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements
okay so highly engageable you know
interactive
allows people to you know really
really take that next step with your
product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads that
we mentioned in the when we're talking
about the type of ads that facebook has
to offer
well lead ads or you know if you have a
lead generation type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information
so if really somebody's interested in
your product or service right away
then you can generate a lead ad and
allow them to
say hey you know what i'm interested i'm
going to sign up for your newsletter
or yes i'm interested in your product or
your future
any future giveaway or promotion you
have to offer
here here's my email address here's my
name here's my phone number
so lead ads are great for consideration
because
somebody knows your ad they've likely
engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your crm
so for example salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point
so that's consideration so we have a lot
of good options available to us
under consideration you know we could
drive traffic
video views app installs just
regular engagement you know and then we
got legion so
we got a lot of opportunities for
consideration if you're really trying to
target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service
and then last but certainly not least we
have messaging
so with messages you know these ads
aim to convert a user's interest in a
product to a successful sale or
conversion so it targets people
who are more likely to respond through
messenger so
facebook messenger is a service that
is integrated nicely in with facebook
and so with facebook messenger
you know you can communicate with that
person
directly just through messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep
who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service
so you can use messenger to your
advantage you can
talk right away to somebody who is
really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
capstone
of consideration because it takes into
account one of facebook's
most popular features which is messenger
and allows you as an advertiser to use
that feature
to engage with your targeted audience
directly let's turn our attention to the
last objective which is conversion
so under conversions we have conversions
product catalog
sales and store visits so for
conversions
really this is the end of the funnel
this is really
the part of the funnel where we want
people to take action
so ads related to the objective of
conversions really
aims to increase you know whatever the
goal is of your website so if it means
signups
or registrations for your services or
sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website
then that's the conversion okay so
that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so
you have conversions and you have your
pure product product
catalog sales so for product catalog
sales these could be ads to help promote
your ecommerce store
or other products in your store
portfolio
you know so think of amazon think about
all the products they have on their
website
you know they are probably likely going
to choose
you know product catalog sales because
it really will help
really push traffic to the store and
really get somebody to convert
either in a for a particular product or
get them to look at other product
categories
and buy something there so really really
product catalog sales are really great
for future campaigns
when you're really looking for sales
and then we have store visits and so
store visits really help direct
traffic to your location and really
helps deliver ads based on your users
current location
okay so if we really want to get
somebody to the store if you have a
brick and mortar store for example
and then you can use store visits as
your objective under conversions
to really drive traffic to that location
so that's what store visits are we
really want people to
you know take that next step get to your
store
and check out your store and purchase so
that's what store visits are
under the conversions objective so
within
each of these advertisement objectives
we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable
from the other so really you have two
advertisements
that really are the same except the only
difference is
there's one thing that's altered from
the other
so in this example we have a with one
promotion
and then we have b which is the same
audience same everything except
a different promotion so you're really
changing
one variable when you do a split test
and so that's available to facebook just
like
any other type of advertising let's say
you do
you know search advertising on google
split testing's available let's say you
do email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same
ad and able to change one of those
parameters
so you can see really what ads performs
best that's the whole idea behind a
split test
okay so if it's the original sales sale
of 25
off then hey so be it you know it works
because you
tested it against another variation
and then the great thing about testing
it never ends so
if 25 off works over say 2
000 off then you try something else to
see
if that will increase sales that's the
whole idea behind testing
is you only want you always want to see
what works okay so
really what it comes down to is it can
be
really it could be a promotional offer
or it could be something as simple as
changing the call to action
you know a different color on the call
to action it could be anything you want
to test
as long as you're able to you know
figure out
what works and then apply what works
so you can continue to improve your
advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so
it really is identifying an element
you want to test and then really once
you identify that element
and you test it and you know it wins
then you can move on other things
to figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion
then go on to the cta so you could test
things like
colors and call to actions and imaging
and messaging and positioning
and you could play around with your
target audience and test a segment of a
target audience against another
so there's lots of things you could test
when you a b
test the most important thing to note
though when you a b
test is you always want to keep in mind
what
metric you want to measure the test up
against so some of the metrics you could
use are click-through rate which is ctr
cost per click cpc you can use
conversion rate also known as cr
or just clicks the whole idea is when
you do a test and you're testing a
promotional offer
you're testing even the call to action
you need to measure
that up against a metric so that metric
is what's going to determine the winner
and so it doesn't have to be overly
complicated it could be as simple as
testing you know one call to action
against another
and determining which one gets more
clicks and if one gets more clicks than
the other then hey
you know you have a winner okay let's go
through the steps of creating a new
campaign
on facebook using facebook's ads manager
so you're gonna log into facebook.com
ads manager
and you're just gonna click on the
create new campaign button
and when you do that you're gonna see a
screen that looks just like this
and you're gonna go through a series of
steps so
as we presented earlier the first step
is always choosing your objective
so we have awareness consideration and
conversion
so recall that awareness was getting
your brand out there to people
who never seen your brand or product or
service before
so it's a matter of trying to reach as
many people as you can
to get your brand out there and so you
have brand awareness
or you have reach remember one is
controlled one is uncontrolled okay
so reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget
okay and you can control your budget a
little bit better
so brand awareness is just getting it
out there
having facebook plop it in front of the
ad in front of as many people as
possible
with reach you are trying to maximize
how many people you show your ad to
but it is a little bit more controlled
against the budget
okay either way choosing awareness is
going to
set the objective of trying to maximize
your exposure for your brand your
product or your service okay if
somebody has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services
then you may want to choose the
objective of consideration
and so these are people who again are
already familiar who
you want to take that next step remember
facebook
is an environment where you're targeting
a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service
so you want to take that next step
that's what you want them to do
okay so here under consideration we have
traffic engagement
app installs video views lead gen or
messages all of these choices are
getting somebody to do something for you
for example app installs you want them
to install your app
or engagement you want them to like or
share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging
you want them to interact with you via
facebook's messenger
uh feature so all of these are
interactions
of some sort where somebody's taking
that next step
they've seen your brand they're
interested but
you they're not ready quite ready to
purchase yet
okay so that's what consideration is
then you have conversion
this is people in the funnel who you
know or think you know want to convert
and when i say think you know
meaning you know you're really targeting
people
who you've targeted before who maybe has
purchased from you before
or is exactly the type of audience
you're looking to purchase
okay so you have conversions you have
catalog sales
and you have store traffic meaning
driving foot traffic to a store
okay so these are people further down
the funnel
who you don't necessarily want to take a
smaller action like just share your
facebook post
or provide their email address and name
okay so you want them to purchase so
these are the three
marketing objectives you're going to
choose from
okay so we're just going to choose
conversions for the sake of this example
and then when we go to choose
conversions remember we can
create a a b split test okay so
that's a choice you should always choose
because you always want to be testing
something
okay in this case we might want to test
the ad we might want to test
say the call to action because we're
looking for conversions
so it could be as simple as having one
ad with a buy more
and the other way that says hey check
out our website
so you have that option to a b split
test and then you have budget
optimization
which basically allows you to
set your budget evenly across your
different ads
okay and so what facebook's gonna do is
basically make sure that the best
performing ad is going to be
seen more often so that's budget
optimization
you're maximizing your budget towards an
ad or
ads that you want to be able to have
more control over in terms of what's
working and what's not working versus
not selecting this option your ads are
just going to randomly show
and there's not going to be any
necessary control over how much spend
each ad gets
so that's the first step in creating
your campaign it's always choosing your
objective with a few options
built in so the next step in the process
is ad set okay and as you can see here
before you even get to ad set
what facebook is prompting us to do is
look at basically how the a b test is
going to work
so here they're explaining how
an a b split test works okay so
basically what an a b split test does is
serve up 50
50. the original versus a variation of
the original
okay so that's more or less how an a b
split test works
and so facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging
okay because that's what we chose now
notice we chose conversions
objective okay so what we're going to be
required to do
is put a conversion pixel on our website
so that facebook can actually track
conversions and so what we want
people to do is purchase and so
what we need to do then is add a
facebook
pixel to our website so that facebook
can actually
track how many people purchase from your
campaign
so this is very important and so if
you're driving traffic to your website
and you want them to convert
then you need to make sure all the
tracking is in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is
setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide
go ahead and select on
because the default is set to off okay
what you could do
is you can associate it with your
particular
company page on facebook and then you're
going to create your offer
so i'm going to put my offer title i'm
going to put a little bit more details
in there
i can put an end date when the offer
expires in a specific time
so based on what you put this is what
people is going to see
with the ad and here you have the
redemption
section where you can have people redeem
the offer online
or online and in store so if it's online
you need to provide facebook with the
url
where people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer
and then you have a chance an
opportunity to add a particular code
so you don't necessarily have to have a
code with your offer
it could be a one-time code it can be a
unique code
okay or unique codes okay and then
you have an advanced option here and
this advanced option is
pretty important because if you're
setting up an
offer and you only want a specific
number of people to see that offer
then and you don't want them to share
that offer then what you could do is
hide the share option
so that way people won't be able to
share the promotion
with friends or family or whatnot now
they could still copy and paste the link
of the offer but they won't be able to
easily do it with the share option
and here you can put some terms and
conditions
so that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer
to get people to you know again your
objective is to get people to convert so
an offer always helps incentivize
conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing
okay so here we're we're choosing what
we want to split test so if we choose
creative
basically what we're doing is we're
telling
facebook we want to test are creative
our ad and so now what we're going to do
is we're going to select the audience
and so we could choose a custom audience
a look-alike or
all so here you can see we have a
look-alike and a look-alike basically
is basically what facebook does is
they're trying to
find people who are very similar to your
customers
okay so that's who you want to target
people who
look like your customers on facebook
okay
so you can choose a look-alike audience
you can choose a custom audience
if you already have one so we're going
to create a new custom audience here
and basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website
visitors okay so we're going to create
this audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell facebook okay
if our audience is all website visitors
where are those visitors going to come
from
so we want to choose a location so it
could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the
location or traveling in a location okay
so here you can see we have it set to
united states
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose
areas or cities and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have
a specific set of locations you can
upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age
so here you have if you look all the way
down to 13 years of age
and then your range goes all the way up
to 65 years of age
then we have our gender we can choose
both men and women or just men
and just women and then we can target
a specific language if we want to target
spanish people
or people who speak spanish then we can
choose spanish
notice we can add multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting
for example we can do interest or
specific behavior so if i click
suggestions
then for example facebook's going to
offer us up some
suggestions so if we want to target
people who have an interest in foreign
language or charity and causes
or mindfulness or it could be specific
job titles
okay so we can get really detailed with
our targeting
we also have connections so who do we
want to target
so are these people who like our page
who are friends of people who
like our page we can also exclude people
who like our page
okay so remember your advertising is
tied to a facebook page
however you could still drive that
traffic
to your website but what facebook does
is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea
of what type of community you have on
facebook okay
so that really helps them offer you
more detailed targeting in the form of
connections okay so when we're done we
could save the audience
so i'm just gonna name it uh english and
spanish
click save okay now i have my audience
saved and the important thing here is
that
this audience is saved we can use it at
a
later date or if we're setting up a new
campaign we can
pull from the same audience under use a
saved audience
so if i just type in english in spanish
you'll see my audience here
okay and we can always edit it if we
need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads
okay so we want to be able to place our
ads
in the proper placement and so what
facebook does
is they actually recommend you do an
auto placement
and so facebook will based on your
audience
show your ad in different spots or
different placements throughout facebook
based on the people you're trying to
target the audience
okay so in this case we're targeting
both spanish and english
okay and we're targeting 13 to 65 year
olds who live in the united states
and so what facebook's going to do then
because we have automatic placement set
up
is they're going to be able to place our
ads based on our target audience so
this is an option i always recommend you
do and facebook recommends as well
if you're specific about where you want
your ad to be placed then you can
just select edit placements and notice
when you select edit placements here
you have different options not only on
facebook but on instagram as well
okay and facebook's network and
in facebook messenger so you have all
these different options available to you
if you really want your your ad
placed in a specific position so here if
i just scroll over here i can see what
it looks like in a feed
in stream video i can scroll down to
instagram that's what it looks like in a
feed on instagram
okay uh you have instagram stories if i
want to go
and advertise on facebook messenger then
i have some options here in messenger
inbox or sponsored messages
okay so you have a lot of options
available under edit placements meaning
picking your placement specifically but
again i recommend as
does facebook just go with the
recommended
placements for now unless you're really
clear and you really understand
how facebook works and where these
placements are actually going to be
but remember if you choose edit
placements and place it in a specific
position
let's just say on messenger inbox
remember your audience
may not be there so going with the
automatic placements
you know is a way for facebook to help
you get your ad in front of the right
audience
here the next section delivery
optimization
okay how much of our ads are optimized
and delivered so
remember we chose conversions here so
we're going to optimize our ads for
conversions
so what facebook's going to do is take
into account
each conversion that each ad is getting
and they're going to show that
ad that's getting more conversions more
often than the ads that aren't getting
as many conversions okay so they're
optimizing the ad delivery
based on how many conversions each ad
gets
and there's an option in here as well so
you can put a cost control in place so
you have an average cost per purchase
okay so facebook will aim to get the
most
purchases and spend your entire budget
okay
if you put in an average cost per
purchase so for example
if i'm selling t-shirts i may not want
my average
cost per purchase to be twenty dollars
because i'm not going to make any money
so i'm probably going to choose maybe
two three four even
as high as five dollars on a cost per
purchase
because i want to make sure i'm not
spending a lot of money
just to get a purchase so you have that
option available to you to put in as a
cost control
and here we have a conversion window and
so what this conversion window is going
to do
is you know help facebook
optimize your ads a little bit better
based on the number of conversions that
happen
in this window okay so you have some
other options in here
you want to do standard delivery ad
scheduling you can
run your ads on a schedule or you can
run them all the time
okay and then moving down to the next
option
in our ad set is we have split test and
split test budget and schedule so we
have the opportunity to put a budget in
place for our ads
okay and we can schedule the
the a b test to start running
immediately if we want to
or we can have the a b test run at a
specific date
and we can have it run for a specific
period of time
so this goes all the way back to the
first option
where we chose a b split test on step
one
so we have a series of options available
to us for the split test
okay once we have all our options in
place
okay we're going to click continue and
then the final step
is actually setting up our ads
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a facebook page
it's going to be tied to an instagram
account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad
so remember we have a lot of different
options available to us on facebook
we have the carousel which allows us to
have
multiple images scrolling horizontally
we can have that single image ad we can
have a video we can have a collection of
images so we have a lot of options
available to us
and then what we could do is we can link
up
our ad to a specific page okay
now before we do that we want to be able
to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay and then we're going to add some
text
to support that image okay and so when
we add text
in for our ad we have the option of
setting up a headline
actually it's not an option it's
actually mandatory the description is
actually
optional okay but my recommendation is
you want to add a headline that's going
to grab attention
and you want to add a description to
support that headline so i always
recommend
putting in a description and then once
you do that
you're going to add your destination url
and then
you're going to be able to preview your
ad okay so
if we have an image here okay we can
just say hey this
come check out our new product
and so as i add this information
i'll be able to view it on the right
side okay so it looks like
facebook at this point is not able to
view the image but
normally you're able to see a preview in
this case it's on the mobile news feed
so if we drop down we can see desktop
right column
okay so we need to really choose our
images so we're going to change an
image here let's see if i can choose
another image
okay i'm going to choose an image here
and so now i can see the image
now i could see the headline um and and
then i could see
what it looks like just by changing the
placement
okay so if i want to choose facebook
stories whoops that's not available
if i go to for example instant articles
okay here i can see what my ad looks
like
on instant articles so wasn't available
on
certain placements because of the type
of ad we chose but the point being
when you set up your ad and you choose
your image and you write your headline
and put your destination url in
then you'll be able to preview it on
certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're once you're set up and
remember we're setting up a b testing so
that was
add one now we want to test the second
ad
or the variation and so basically what
we want to do
is choose the same type of format
then what we want to do is pick a
variation what is that variation going
to be
it could be maybe just a different
headline
okay or it could be a different url you
need to decide what it is you're going
to test
once you decide what you test you're
going to add that to variation b
once you add that the variation b then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria
okay and if it doesn't in this case you
can see we have some errors
then we need to go back and fix them so
i'm going to go back and choose single
image ad
okay so now i could just choose my one
image so i can browse a library of
images i already
have now here's my single image ad
i'm going to add some text in there a
website url
a headline remember you want it to be
catchy
okay you can change the call to action
here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type
of format you choose so remember we
chose a b
test so we're going to
set up both ads add a and add b
okay and when we do that again we can
have facebook review it
once they review it we they can confirm
this you can see we still have some
errors on
add a so let's go ahead and fix that i'm
going to choose single image because
that's what
add b is i'm going to browse my library
maybe i'll just test a different
image i'm going to click continue and
so basically keep everything the same
what i'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an a b test
knowing what it
is you want to test ahead of time
okay once you do that you're going to go
ahead and continue to add b
and then once you do that um here let's
go ahead and fix this error here
um the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add b once i confirm
then i have two ads ready to go on
specific
placements or excuse me automatic
placements and this option is that's the
option we chose
and basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions
we have a set budget and we're going to
be able to then
once our ads go live is look at some
reports
to see how they're performing so that's
the steps in
setting up a campaign on facebook you're
choosing your objective
okay then you're setting up your ad set
okay
and then once you set up your ad set
with your target audience
then you're actually going through the
motions in this case we set up two ads
because we chose a b testing okay
and if you didn't choose a b testing
then you would just choose
to set up the first ad and once you do
that you confirm
and voila your campaign is set up based
on these three steps
okay so let's uh review with some do's
and don'ts of facebook
so we mentioned the types of ad that
facebook has we mentioned
how to set up a facebook ad itself and
choosing the right
objectives and so some of the do's
involved are
what's just what i mentioned we always
want to do a b testing on our ads
whether that's again just changing out
the color we're changing out an image
you always want to do a b
testing because facebook has you know
carousel ads and because they have
you know ads that can rotate and you can
use even video with your ads
you always want to take advantage of
what's given to you and so facebook
allows you to do it
do it so if you have the opportunity to
have a video at
then use the video ad highly recommend
it remember video ads have higher
engagement
so definite do is use engaging
videos and imagery so you don't
necessarily have to use a static ad
or image ad you can use the carousel for
example
or the presentation mode where you can
show multiple images
to really showcase your product and
service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so use a message that will stay with the
audience
okay so use something that's going to be
able
to trigger remember it depends on the
funnel and where you're at so if your
awareness or consideration or conversion
that has to align with your messaging so
if you're you know targeting ads
you know when you want people to convert
then your message is going to be
as such you're going to talk to people
as if you want them to convert as if
they're ready to convert
and you want to keep your message
consistent and simple
so remember the ads are available to you
and you have so many different features
available to you within those ads
but that doesn't mean you gotta
convolute it with messaging so
keep your message consistent and simple
if it's brand awareness
you know definitely keep your message
simple so that people can understand
exactly what it is your product or
service is all about
then you want to alter your reach so
that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience
okay so you always want to keep in mind
who you're trying to target
okay so you don't want to target
somebody who's not in your demographic
so alter your reach so that the ads are
shown to the appropriate audience
remember
you have you know reach available to you
and reach allows you
to really pick and choose exactly
who you're targeting to and how often
remember you want to reach as many
people as possible but you don't want to
reach the wrong
people some of the don'ts to stay some
things you want to stay away from
is you don't want to put all your money
on one campaign
so you want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across
different campaigns and i would even
take that a step further
and you know put different types of ads
in different campaigns
just to see what works so again it
depends on
where you're at in the funnel if it's
just brand awareness okay maybe create a
campaign for that if it's consideration
create a campaign for that because in
consideration you might have lead ads
in there i say with the awareness
campaign you may just have a single
image ad
okay just to introduce your product to
somebody with a simple message
so you want to you know definitely
think about how you want to separate out
your campaigns but
don't be afraid to separate your
campaigns by the type of ads
don't put too much information in the
ads remember
keep it consistent and keep it simple
that's the best
thing i can say and remember a lot of
these ads are image based so images tell
a thousand
words they tell a thousand stories a
video will do the job
if you have to say too much so if you're
saying too much think about a video
but if you're using an image let the
image tell the story
okay don't forget to proofread your ads
i can't stress that enough
remember if you're an awareness campaign
this is the first time somebody's seen
your product or service so you
definitely want to get the
messaging not only correct meaning
consistent and simple
but grammatically correct you don't want
to be so
active on your facebook page so you know
when i say
being don't be so active on your
facebook page really
it depends on where you're at you're
trying to introduce a product or service
so that doesn't mean that you need to
go out and tell everybody to start
buying your product
remember these people may not even know
who you are
what product and service you offer so
you want to be able to approach
your audience on your facebook page in a
manner
which is suitable for your audience and
then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so
you you want to be able to you know have
an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific
audience with a specific product then
make sure the image on your facebook
page aligns with that
okay don't be inconsistent don't confuse
the audience
you know be consistent with your imagery
as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don't see
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising
one of the biggest challenges facebook
faces is to keep
people and businesses happy with
continuously driving change in its
functionality
recently new challenges have been added
in this light of privacy of user data
and fake news
the engine of facebook's platform to
drive
all these changes is the facebook
algorithm
understanding facebook without
understanding the facebook algorithm
will limit you in efforts to use
facebook successfully
by the end of this lesson you will be
able
to discuss the recent news feed changes
to explain the concept of
organic reach in facebook explain the
new facebook algorithm and its main
components
identify the three active interactions
in the facebook algorithm
and discuss the future of the facebook
news feed
the facebook algorithm is facebook's
secret source
in which is decided which post to show
in your news feed
whether it's your friend's post or a
post from a business
facebook has recently announced a
cleanup of the news feed
which particularly affects how
businesses should use facebook
it is now commonly understood by
businesses
that to use facebook successfully they
have to
pay to play in this lesson you will
learn about these facebook changes in
the algorithm
and what you can do to improve your
organic reach
and we will close the lesson with
looking at the future of the news feed
the facebook news feed and organic reach
the facebook news feed is the core of
the facebook platform
it was launched as far back as 2006
and it has seen many iterations since
initially the newsfeed was the place to
see posts from your facebook friends
it was the facebook way to stay up to
date
and the facebook algorithm decides which
posts show up
in what order on top of the feed you see
the what's on your mind
in which you can do your own status
updates and it allows you to add photos
videos tech people check-in and so on
facebook continuously adds new features
that you can add to your updates
newsfeed is the place where you can see
the activities of your friends and the
pages that you follow
you can access the news feed on the
mobile app
or on your desktop i'm going to show
here how to access your news feed on the
desktop
by clicking here on the home button you
get access to your news feed and in the
news feed
you can see all the posts on the top of
the news feed you have your create post
section i will come back to that later
and then immediately below that
you can see the posts of the various
companies that you follow
or the people that that are your friends
and obviously the
facebook algorithm and that's what we're
talking about in this module
will decide which posts it will
show based on your activities of your
friends
how engaging are their posts and how
many comments are they getting on their
posts
and that is a whole sort of calculation
that facebook does
to make sure it shows the most engaging
post in your news feed
you can see how many likes they get how
many comments so you see this is a very
engaging post
and here you can like comment share the
post
yourself if i click on the company name
for instance here
then i would go to the company page and
then on the company page i can see all
the posts
that company has done and not
necessarily all those pages have made
posts
have made it to your news feed companies
can use facebook
by setting up a facebook page and get
people to
like the page and become a fan posts
done by the company
would then show up in the news feed of
their fans
in the early days of the facebook pages
this was like the gold rush of the 18th
century in america
companies like coca-cola got tens of
millions of fans
and had a tremendous exposure on
facebook and all for free
but when facebook started to monetize
their business through advertising
they needed to find a way to push
businesses
in using facebook advertising the way
they did this
was to slowly erode the organic reach in
facebook let's look at this organic
reach in a bit more detail
on this slide you see how organic reach
has dropped over the years
and how the facebook share price has
increased they are clearly related
the share price has gone up because a
continuous drop in organic reach
forced businesses to use facebook
advertising
to reach their audiences and this
strategy clearly works
what started as small-scale advertising
opportunities for businesses
on the side of the news feed than in the
news feed
and then on the mobile next businesses
could advertise in videos
and with the acquisition of instagram
and the launch of the new facebook
messenger
new advertising opportunities emerged
for businesses
but this drive towards growing
advertising revenues came at a price
where the news feed once was the place
where friends posted updates on what
they were doing
it became a garbage bin of business
posts ads
travel videos fake news quotes
and other irrelevant stuff practically
impossible for the algorithm to manage
you may have noticed this yourself when
you checked your news feed over the
years
it used to be a place where your friends
shared what they were doing
and it became a place where you could
find stuff
that the facebook algorithm believed you
liked
facebook knew it had to do something
about this
the growth in new users was slowing down
there was an increase in fake accounts
fake ads and fake news
and on top of that there were many
issues on data privacy
that got reinforced because of the
introduction of the gdpr
so it was time for a change the facebook
algorithm
today january 13th
2018 goes into the facebook history as a
significant day
so much so that facebook lost nearly 119
billion dollars market value in one day
it was the day that facebook announced
to clean up the news feed
zuckerberg said in a statement that they
got feedback from their community
that public content like posts from
businesses brands and
media are crowding out the personal
moments that lead people to connect with
each other
zuckerberg continues that it's easy to
understand how we got there
video and other public content have
exploded on facebook in the last few
years
but what he doesn't say is that facebook
is a big culprit itself in polluting the
news feed
by pushing more and more businesses into
advertising
and by offering more and more places on
facebook
instagram and messenger to advertise
and all this pollution of the facebook
news feed
is driving facebook away from the most
important
thing it does helping people
to connect with each other to cut a long
story short
facebook has dropped organic reach to
less than
three percent and businesses now
understand
that they have to pay to play or in
other words
use facebook advertising to reach their
audience
so where in the early years of the
facebook page you could build your
audience
and your brand organically on facebook
and then use facebook ads to give your
reach a boost
nowadays you have to pay to play but
don't let it scare you
it doesn't have to be expensive and
facebook has created
an amazing advertising platform that can
help you
achieve your business goals and don't
worry
there are still ways that you can beat
the facebook algorithm
and improve your organic reach in the
next few slides and lessons we will
explain you
how to do this so let's look at today's
facebook algorithm in a bit more detail
the facebook algorithm has to make sure
that it selects the most
relevant posts for you from the
thousands of potential posts
that may be displayed in your news feed
it analyzes the posts and arranges them
in a way
that you would like to see them its aim
is to give you
a better overall experience
it does this by looking at four
different elements
it looks at all the available posts it
analyzes these posts on various factors
called signals
and it predicts how you would react to
the posts
it then summarizes all this with a score
and the posts with the highest score
will feature higher in your news feed
let me explain the signals to you on the
next slide
these are the signals facebook looked at
before the cleanup announcement
time spent on the content overall
engagement
when it was posted story type how
informative is the post
but with the cleanup facebook fine-tuned
the algorithm
and here is what it's looking for now
the facebook algorithm will now put
extra focus on the engagement on a post
and the usage of other facebook tools
like facebook live or facebook messenger
which means
business posts that do not drive
engagement
like commenting and sharing will not
show up in the news feed
posts with short videos quotes quizzes
polls
and links to other websites are now
being demoted
so what can you as a business do about
this
that's not an easy question and many
businesses are still
searching for the answer to this but let
me give you a few tips
let's look at today's top ranking
factors in facebook
top ranking factors in the facebook
algorithm
for the cleanup of the news feed
businesses use their posts to get people
to click
we call this link bait to watch a video
or view an image
by hovering over it these were all
passive actions
nothing to do with engagement in the new
algorithm
facebook now looks at three interactions
commenting sharing and reacting
commenting is at the core of the updated
facebook algorithm
posts that will lead to high volume of
comments
will show high in the news feed these
are the posts to generate
conversations between people comment
baiting is
definitely a no-no in facebook these
days
facebook will demote posts that use
engagement bait
like comment vote react or share
the algorithm will also reward posts
that are being shared
facebook likes posts that are shared
within messenger
and also business posts that have
engagement when shared by friends
but sharing alone is not enough facebook
will favor
those posts that are shared and lead to
conversations between people
facebook also likes it when you use
reactions
although not as powerful as comments and
shares but it remains a form of active
engagement
facebook will promote your business
posts to more people
when people use the reactions buttons on
your posts
so here are the new tactics that will
help you increase
your organic reach of your business
posts call for quality
instead of quantity post once a day
instead of five times a day understand
and analyze your fans check when they
are online and post accordingly
think about your content create
specifically for facebook and use
video and facebook live facebook live is
a key tool that will help you
improve your organic reach there is also
a little secret
in facebook called see first when
somebody likes your page
it is set at default when they like your
page which means
all your business posts will go through
the facebook algorithm
but when you set it as c first your post
will
guaranteed show up at the top of the
news feed of your fan
analyze your posts and see which posts
have
lots of engagement recycle these posts
or boost them with advertising
learn from other facebook pages
experiment with your content
and certainly make sure that you will
reply on every comment you are getting
another way of driving your organic
reach is to start using facebook groups
facebook has revamped the group
functionality recently
and are promoting groups to be used by
businesses as well
and this brings us back to the basics of
marketing
by implementing these new algorithm
changes
facebook now forces businesses to
understand
their customer to understand their
target audiences
to understand their challenges their
motivations what they like to interact
with
what they care about because only then
will you be able to create
content that sparks emotion because
emotions will generate
comments likes and shares the future of
the facebook news feed
so what will happen with the news feed
when we look into the future
the news feed has been around for more
than 10 years now
and the concept has become a bit
outdated
obviously it won't disappear straight
away but there are many new features
emerging
that will drive new types of engagement
if we look at
stories messaging facebook live
and community features like marketplace
dating
these are areas where you don't need a
news feed and where you naturally find
more engagement
instagram is a good example of this it's
a fact that today's instagram users
spend more time in looking at people's
stories
than spending time on the instagram
newsfeed
but for now make sure you understand the
news feed
and you understand the facebook
algorithm because that will put you in
an excellent position
to take advantage of everything that
facebook has to offer
here are the highlights of this lesson
recently facebook announced that it
would
update the facebook algorithm to only
show
posts in the news feed to lead to
genuine conversations
between people as a result organic reach
for business posts on facebook has
dropped
to the lowest position ever most
businesses now
understand that to reach their audience
on facebook
they have to pay to play which means
using facebook ads fortunately there are
still ways to beat
the new facebook algorithm using
facebook live is one of them
with the increase in commerce on the
internet it is obvious
that e-commerce is also moving into
facebook
in fact for years social commerce has
been an important word in mark
zuckerberg's vocabulary
enabling people to open a shop front in
facebook
and then linking it to their existing
online shop
but the next step is to let all this
commerce take place
in facebook and of course on the mobile
on top of that facebook now features
many different ad types that shops can
use
to promote their products linking back
to the online store
now watch this space we've only seen the
tip of the iceberg
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to set up a facebook shop
connect your facebook shop with
e-commerce sites like shopify
create a facebook catalog use facebook
dynamic
ads to promote specific products and
promote your facebook shop
facebook has many options for e-commerce
you can set up a shop on your facebook
page
and tailor it to your own products these
products can be presented on your page
and you can advertise for them as well
and you can also add a catalog
to your shop which gives you the
opportunity to promote
and target your product advertising more
specifically
setting up your facebook shop facebook
allows you to set up shop
on your facebook page by doing this you
can promote your products on facebook
and offer prices for your product
you can also add a shop now button once
people click on the products it will
take them
to their website where they can place
the order they want to buy directly into
the shopping trolley
setting up a facebook shop has many
advantages
you don't need an existing catalog so
you can add an
unlimited number of products you want to
feature in your shop
like any shopping catalogue facebook
allows you to organize your products in
collections
so people can easily find the products
they are looking for
and by activating the messaging button
people can ask questions
or even place an order
to create your facebook shop you have to
add a shop
tab here on the left side menu now the
way to do that
is to go to the settings and then in the
settings you click on the templates and
tabs and then here you see you currently
haven't got the
shop as a tab so you click add tab
and that's where you have shop so you
simply click add
tab and that means your shop has been
added
and then you can drag the shop to a
higher level
in the tab menu and then you can go to
the
settings of the shop where you can
switch it on and off
and where you can also copy the url of
the shop
but the main settings of the shop are
also within
the tab when you are on your page
so now that we've installed the tab for
shop
you now see on your home page of your
facebook page
you see as the third item the shop click
on the shop
and the first thing obviously you need
to do is to agree
to the terms and conditions for your
shop
you click continue and then you're
basically going to
set up all the details in your shop now
the first question you need to answer
yourself
is how do you want people to buy the
products from your shop
they can either send you a message to
buy
you can activate that or you can drive
them to your website for instance where
you have your online shop
you can just get them to the link of
that particular page
so for this demo sake let's click
message to buy
and we'll click on continue you select
the currency
and then you click save and you're
getting to the next screen
of your shop setup where you're going to
add
products and you can also add the
description
of what you sell so when i click here on
the scribe
what simply business sells i have 200
characters to describe
what my business does so i can just add
for instance for the
demo sake social media training
products and services and i click save
changes
and then i'm going to add products so if
i click on add product
you're going to add visuals for your
product you can add a video of your
product you can add
name the price whether the product is on
sale
a description of the product whether you
want to share this
product on your facebook page you can
give
inventory information different options
about your product like sizes and colors
and how you want it to show up
on your page and who do you want to be
able to see the
the product so let's add some products
so here we're going to go to the
photos that we're dragging from the
the desktop so let's say that is product
one
and we're going to use that this is
social media book and the price
is 10 pounds and the description
how to attract
date and love your
customers on social media
i'm just going to leave these as
standard options and i click
save and now i have my first product
added and i can add more products so you
see how the product
features in the product list i can add
my next
product and
add a photo selective files here i'm
going to product number two
and this is social
media training and we'll say
that is 50 pounds description
introduction
to social media
keeping those settings standard that's
product two
and then i'm going to add product three
product three is let's say a
linkedin training
and i'm going to say again linkedin
training the price is 50 pounds
i'm clicking save and then the fourth
product that i will be adding
is product for and that would be the
facebook training
and that would be let's say 50 pounds as
well
intro
production to facebook
and i'm clicking save yeah if i now do a
refresh of the page
you will see that all the products show
up now there is another
area where you can actually put products
in different collections
so for instance if i want to do the
facebook training and the linkedin
training
in a collection i can then click here
add collection
yeah so these are the products that are
currently in the catalog but if i'm
going to add a collection
i'm going to say training product
yep and then i can add the products to
the collection the one i wanted was
facebook training
and linkedin training i've now added
two products to this collection and i
can then click
save and if i now go back
to my shop so let's go to the page
and i'll go to the shop you now see that
i
have two collections
that i can sort of scan and browse
through
and i have my different products
so i can now start promoting my shop
through facebook advertising
or by sharing particular products from
my shop
on my timeline here you see an example
of a facebook shop
you can see the desktop and the mobile
version of it
on the desktop you can see the shop tab
on the left you can decide what position
the shop takes in the tab
listing you can do this in the settings
you can see the products by category and
also you see the shop now button and the
send message
on the mobile you can show the product
specs a photo
the price the details and the link to
the website
in the shop setup you can manage all
aspects of running your facebook shop
you can add products you can add
collections you can get an overview
of the orders and the pending orders the
facebook shop
also allows you to tag products you can
tag up to 30 products and links in your
shop
you tag these in your page posts when
people see your product tags in your
posts
they can then click on the tag to shop
for the tagged product
finally it is important to connect your
facebook page with a payment engine
you can set up your payment within your
facebook page
so people can buy your products directly
on your page
but this only works in the us for those
shops outside the us
you need to integrate your facebook shop
with e-commerce platforms
like shopify fortunately many online
store builders
who have e-commerce engines can
integrate your existing products on
their store with your facebook page
this means that you can connect your
existing online shop with facebook
and your existing products will
automatically be uploaded
in your new facebook shop creating your
facebook catalogue
to expand the capabilities of your
facebook shop you should use
or set up a facebook catalog consider
this catalog as a folder
with all the products you want to
promote and advertise
once you've set up your facebook catalog
you can target people with specific
product
ads based on their browsing behavior in
your shop
for example when somebody clicked on a
specific product in your shop
you can target them with an ad for that
product the next time they are on
facebook
now that your shop is ready you can
target
people who visit your shop or your
online shop on your website
through setting up a facebook catalog
now in order to set up a facebook
catalog you have to be
in the ads manager and when you click
here on the ads manager
you go down under assets and that's
where you see
catalogs because we've created a catalog
when we set up our shop
it will automatically show up here in
your list of catalogs
and when you click on the catalog you
get to the screen where you can
select different type of ads that you
want to run
for the particular products you can see
what products do we have in our catalog
what product sets do we have in our
catalog
and what are the data sources for the
catalog that we're using
and there is the settings for your
catalogue as well
like what's the name of your catalog
what notification settings
etc so back to the diagnostics area of
your catalog
this is where you are going to decide
what type of ad
you're going to use for your catalog so
you can have
generic ads or you can have dynamic ads
generic ads is basically where you can
feature
an ad for a specific product in your
catalog
or when you do a dynamic ad you can
actually
retarget people who see specific
products on your website and they can
then receive an
ad with that particular product that
they saw on your website
but then on their facebook just as a
little reminder
that may push them to buy the product so
if i click on the
ad to drive traffic it will ask you
which accounts do you want to use
and then it takes you to the ad manager
where you go
through the standard process of your
campaign
settings your ad account settings your
ad set
and the creation of the ad itself now
i'm not going to show you all the
details of how to create an ad
we've done that in other demos but in
very important section
that you have here is that you can
create an instant experience
which is a much more multimedia type ad
that you can select within your catalog
for instance you can check which
products do we want to select for the ad
how do you want to order the products
like dynamically
or you can even specify in order are
there specific
sort of collections that you want to use
for this ad
where do you want to use a cover video
or a cover image
and then what is the call to action
button that you want on your ad
and once you're done with that you're
going back
into the ad set creation where you are
looking into the traffic for the ad
and the audience segmentation and then
you follow
the process of developing your ad
using facebook dynamic ads here are a
few more details about the facebook
dynamic ads
they promote products from your catalog
to people who are more likely to respond
to them
because they have seen that particular
product before in your shop
or in your app or they have shown an
interest in the category
for instance if people are browsing
hotels on your website
but don't make a reservation you can
then target them with specific product
ads from your catalog based on their
travel preferences
finally it is important that you promote
your facebook shop
there are many ways you can do that you
can promote your products by making them
stand out
through videos and really good
photography
and another effective way of promoting
your shop is by enabling ratings and
reviews
often people look at customer reviews
before making a buying decision
and if you have a physical store it will
also help if you add
all your shop details like the address
and the opening times
and it goes without saying that when
people message you with questions
or even an order make sure you respond
instantly
so what did we learn in this lesson
setting up a facebook shop will enable
you to
list and promote products you sell you
can even connect your shop with
e-commerce sites like shopify
you can set up a facebook catalog that
holds all the items you want to promote
across all of facebook social media
platforms
and facebook dynamic ads automatically
promote products to people
who have expressed interest on your
website or in your app
three simple elements for promoting your
shop respond quickly to messages from
customers
encourage people to leave reviews and
add the address of your physical store
facebook live setup and how to use for
business
the final facebook tool that businesses
can use is facebook live
which basically allows you to live
stream
video to your facebook audience live
streaming started on twitter a few years
ago through periscope
it soon moved to youtube and facebook
and is now
a really exciting communication tool to
connect
instantly with your audience live
streaming
has called the media world by surprise
i can now be at a live concert and
stream it live to my facebook friends
where do media rights fit into this the
industry is still
trying to come up with answers fact is
that facebook live allows you to start
your own
live tv program and broadcast it
instantly
to a global facebook audience and on top
of this
facebook loves you to use facebook live
and will reward you for using it
by giving your facebook live post a
higher organic reach
facebook live has lots of opportunities
for businesses
it gives natural engagement by people
liking
and commenting during the live broadcast
and facebook gives you lots of
opportunities to promote the live event
before and after the live broadcast
at the end of the broadcast facebook
will ask you if you want to save the
broadcast
and post it on your feed often this
leads to
lots of additional views and engagements
on this site you can see where in the
world
facebook live broadcasts are happening
right now
you also see a lot of live activity in
southeast asia
so let's look at some of the features
facebook live
covers three aspects of communication
first
it allows you to have live conversations
with your followers
and facebook live turns these
conversations in very engaging
experiences
with likes and emoticons flowing over
the screen as they come in
and comments showing up as well second
you can turn your live broadcast into a
visual story
like you want to tell it you can add
filters colors
texts overlays etc adding augmented
reality features
is not far away and thirdly
you can target audiences in multiple
ways for your broadcasts
and on top of that facebook will give
your live broadcast
a higher than average organic reach
allspice brazil is a great example of a
facebook live campaign
they did a two-day live broadcast to put
their anti-perspirant products to the
test
they turned it into a big marketing
campaign
with which they reached over 9 million
people with the time of the broadcast
there are many ways businesses can use
facebook live
it's a great tool for promoting your
products or services
you can do live tutorials or product
launches
it can be used to support your live
events
you can do a broadcast during your event
and interview an expert who attends the
event
it can also be used to support your
customers
you can do a live q a ask for feedback
hold a webinar
and facebook live also lends itself for
sharing news
announce a sale or organizes sales party
lots of opportunities it may take a
while to build traction with your
broadcast
but if you can maintain the momentum you
can generate
plenty of coverage and engagement a good
way to maintain
engagement is to turn your live
broadcasts into recurring episodes
weekly or monthly
so you can build your campaign around
this and build up a library
of great content
it is very easy to start your facebook
live
video when you are on your company page
what you do you click on the publish
button
on your mobile and then in the different
options you see
one of them is live video you click on
your live video
you immediately see what you want on the
the screen you can have different
background settings if you want to
different filters you can select where
you want to uh to post
and you can then basically click start
the live button when you start a live
button
your life you can still add different
effects you can invite people
you can chat and basically we are now
live
if i now would go to my other phone and
let me just quickly do that i will go
to facebook and i will go
to the facebook page so of simply learn
and i can see that facebook
let me go here yeah so i go to the
simply
simply learn business page and i can
then
see that the video is live on
the page from simplylearn and
here i can then engage with the page you
can also see here in the screen
that i have one viewer and that is me in
this case
here you can also see that i can like
and this is i think a
really cool feature of the facebook live
which shows you the engagement
that is happening during the broadcast
it can be a thumbs up it can be a heart
it can be a smiley face
and i've seen companies do polls
give me a smiley face if you like the
product give me a sad face
if you're not happy with the with the
product and then you can count the
number of likes
that come in in that way you can also
see who is watching and that's in this
case is marketman
i can then also put in a comment to this
post and i can just say hi
and post it and that comment that will
show up
on the feed as well so a very engaging
very
interactive process to run your facebook
live broadcasts
so when i click finish then what
facebook will do
is will save the video and it will then
give you the option
to save it on your newsfeed
on your timeline you can upload it in
high definition
so when you save it on your timeline
then you can share it straight away
or you can save it on your disk i click
share
and now you see that on my business page
in a minute the page
the the live broadcast will show up
actually it's already shown up here
and you can then see who was on the the
video
yep you see the comment that came in and
you can see the video and you can see
the engagement in
the video as well so very powerful
concept
to run facebook live broadcasts
greetings everyone this is rob
sanders and today i'm going to
present facebook advertising tips and
strategies
so thank you for joining today we're
going to cover a number of
tips to help you gain a better advantage
on advertising
on facebook so let's get right to it
with tip number one
and with tip number one not all
advertisements need to sell something
so remember you have different
objectives on facebook
you can advertise an event you can
promote a customer story
you can send traffic to your website or
you can get them to download an app so
it all goes back
to your objective so if we go to
facebook
and i want to create an ad remember
my first option is to create an
objective
so you have awareness you have
consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do
that's the objective you're going to
choose so just keep that in mind when
you're setting up your campaign on
facebook
you need to align your objective with
what you want people to do
tip number two we want to use facebook
messenger for advertising so
facebook messenger is a feature that can
be used with advertising
on facebook and it's a good tool it's a
good practice because it allow you
to as the advertiser to commute with
individuals directly
so it's a feature that you should take
advantage of because it allows you to
quickly
engage with your target audience so
that's the beauty of
leveraging facebook messenger with your
advertising the communication tools
available
and for you to engage with your target
audience
so it's great for not only interacting
but taking care of any other objections
that they have as an
as an audience or prospective client so
you can answer
any concerns they have right away so
it's a lot more personal
and interactive than other forms of
advertising because
you're directly communicating with your
audience tip three
use video advertisements i can't stress
this enough
video is very engaging in fact it's not
only engaging but it's very
easy to use so we go to facebook
really facebook is telling us for video
all we need to do
is have basically a phone handy and
an app and just to be able to upload it
so
with facebook video you can really drive
awareness
and you can really drive sales when you
can really make some really splashy
videos on facebook
all you need is a mobile camera so with
facebook videos
it's really very easy to create you just
gotta be creative that's really the key
to videos
you know they're gonna be engaging to
the end user say something
do something that's gonna really grab
their attention and get them to do what
you want them to do so these are just
some of the examples you can see
on facebook and you can see how creative
advertisers are getting you know clear
call to action
great video or great imagery good
promotional use
so there's a lot you can do with video
and really make it interactive so
i can't stress video enough as an option
for facebook
it really is one of the better features
of facebook advertising and really
very limited use of resources all you
need is that web camera
an app and the ability to upload that
video that's really it
for video advertisements so keep in mind
and the reason why i'm harping on those
video ads is they
tend to outperform your traditional
facebook image ads and other formats
like the carousel
or the presentation mode so there's
other types of formats on facebook
video tends to give it that extra edge
because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement
so in this example you know people are
going to react they're going to comment
they're going to share the video
and that's what you want as an
advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it will help you
not only engage with the person but
allow that video to be shared
and expand your reach towards your
target audience so
remember video can range from a few
seconds all the way up to 120 minutes
so you're really gonna get more views
regardless of how long the video is
because it's just gonna be so
interactive so
just keep that in mind it doesn't have
to be full on 120 minutes it could be
you know anywhere from one to five
minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to
so remember video ads always perform
better than single image ads
or other type of image ad formats on
facebook
and they also perform better when they
have subtitle support so just keep that
in mind as well
because you may have you know
individuals watching the video from
you know different countries speaking
different languages say tip four
when you're placing your advertisement
where you place your advertising will
play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so facebook offers a number of
different options to choose from
so remember you got the news feed you
got instant articles
right column you got suggested videos so
you got a lot of options at your
disposal
there's lots of other options too so you
can have
facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the facebook
setup so if we go to facebook and then
we go to create your campaign
so if we close ad set here is where
we're going to be able to
choose our placement if we click on
choose placement we'll be able to
you know be able to allow facebook to
place it
or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again
feeds and stuff articles in-stream
videos
you got rycom you even have instagram so
you have a lot of
options available to you so my
recommendation and facebook's
recommendation is always go with the
auto placement
but you could specifically choose your
placement if you want to
when you're setting up your campaign so
start the advertising
on the news feed could be recommended
the news feed is where you're probably
going to get your most eyeballs
most users spend most of their time
there and it has the highest chance of
grabbing their attention so the newsfeed
could be a good place to start again you
can have it at auto placement
and your ads may be there as well or you
can specifically choose just the news
feed
or other placements so tip four just be
careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you wanna place your ad where
you're gonna get eyeballs so tip five
facebook ads also offer you the option
to advertise on instagram so you have
that
option available to you as i mentioned
in tip four you have the option to
advertise through stories
carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part
of the ad setup when you go to choose
your placements
here you got instagram feed you get
instagram stories and again
with both of those placements on
instagram you can work
with several different types of ads
including that carousel ad including
that video ad
so just keep that in mind that instagram
is an option for you
take advantage of it there's a lot more
eyeballs on instagram these days
and it plays off nicely with what you're
trying to do with facebook so go ahead
and give it a try okay so let's take a
quick break from the first few tips we
went over
and let's take a look at an ad so
it's an ad break time so let's take a
look at this
and this is by new scientist and so what
makes this ad
so great well there's been a lot of
shake up in the world today about fake
news you know what is fake news so
new scientist is actually playing off of
that they're
mentioning hey fake news not in our
world so they're actually playing off of
that
that term fake news and so that's an
attention grabber so i think that's what
makes
this look so good but this is a single
image ad and you can see here
they're promoting this ad with a
promotion so try
12 weeks for just 36 euros okay so they
have a promotion in there so
and you notice they the image of the you
know the magazine
they're also displaying that hey you can
look at this digitally on a laptop
a tablet or a mobile phone so you have
other options as well so they show you
that in the image which is placed on the
right
side of their messaging so for me this
is a good ad because of the placement
of the image the type of image they're
using the play on fake news
and the promotion that they're offering
up so this is really a good ad
it's very eye-catching and hopefully the
promotion's good enough
to get you to sign up okay so tip number
six so tip number six we want to
continuously
do a b testing you want to always have
this
option going for you want to be able to
test
variation a versus variation b because
you want to be able to find out
what works and what doesn't work with
your audience and on top of that
it helps you really put your best foot
forward by
showing your best ad so by doing a b
testing
you're getting feedback from the
audience and turning that feedback
into positive returns so you're then
turning your
ad that does work well in front of an
audience and you're going to continue to
do that
so a b testing is always a good option
so remember
when you're setting up your ad in
facebook go ahead and
choose to have your a b test set up and
when you do that
you choose that option you're going to
be able to then go in
and choose what it is you want to test
with that a and then with add b
so you're going to again align your
tests with a facebook page you're going
to choose an
ad format once you choose your ad format
then you're going to be able to
go ahead and you know put your ad in
there
and then you're going to choose your
call to action so the whole idea behind
an a b
test is you want to be able to find
what it is you want to test is that
going to be the
call to action is it going to be the
messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
can test with facebook on a b
testing so it's all part of the ad setup
so things you can change again are the
color of the elements
imaging text the call to action the
position of the ad there's lots of
things you could test
that's all part of the facebook setup so
the thing is you want to continuously
test
that's the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad
so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so
my advice is when you're actually
setting this up on facebook
you know think ahead think what it is
you want to choose to test
my advice is maybe start out with a call
to action so if you're in facebook
itself
you know you have an opportunity to test
different call to actions
try that that's an easy way to test and
then
you know when you test the call to
action once you find out what works and
doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe
the image type or maybe trying different
types of imagery or
ad types like the carousel versus single
image
so start small start easy and then work
your way up
tip number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action
in your advertisements that will attract
potential customers
so what do we mean well you have
different call to actions available to
you you want to choose one that aligns
with your ad
so for example the simply learn ad about
hey learn how seo works search engine
optimization
so if you're trying to get somebody to
you know learn or take one of your
courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up
so that's the key we want them to sign
up so use a call to action that makes
sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean
so for this you can consider you know
website visits
interest it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do
if it's you know customers in the buying
process
then that's our objective is to get
conversions then we want to move
somebody over
to a product page and get them to
purchase you know if it's focusing on
just website visits
then maybe it's the objective of
consideration
maybe you just want to get people to
your website to learn more about your
product
so that's the whole idea behind you know
choosing
uh the right you know objective because
you want to align the objective with
your ad
okay so tip number nine create look
alike
audiences and i'd like lookalike
audience because what facebook does
is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you already
advertising to or customer base you
already have
so in other words facebook already has
an idea
of who your audience is you can also you
know provide them with additional
information like an email list to give
them a better
sense of who your audience is and then
what facebook does is they take that
information
and they'll put your ad in front of an
audience that
looks just like the audience you already
have that's why they call it a
look-alike audience so
it's a great feature by facebook it
really allows you
to reach a target audience an audience
is
very similar to the audience you
currently have in one example
provide facebook with an email list with
that email list they're going to be able
to map that email list
and be able to identify an audience that
you could target
so that's the whole idea behind
lookalike audience it's a great feature
by facebook
definitely recommend taking advantage of
that why because it will increase the
number of people
who will find your advertisement
relevant remember
you're targeting people who are similar
to your actual audience to your
the people who are already connected
with your brand or already
liking your page so if they're similar
to those people
then the chances of them engaging with
you are going to be greater
so look alike audiences tend to perform
well because you're targeting an
audience that's very similar to your
actual audience
tip number 10 so use the golden point
rule on your ad creator so
what do we mean by golden point rule
well let's take this ad here
as an example so what we want to do is
we want to
divide the creative into nine equally
sized boxes
so what we want to do is draw two
horizontal lines and two vertical lines
just like a tic tac toe box
and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main
subject of your ad in the cross sections
of the drawn lines and so what that does
is encourages the user to place their
focus
on those points the lines are just
simply there is a guidance to help you
position
your messaging so that's the golden
point rule really is we want to be able
to position our messaging accordingly
so time for another ad break so let's
take a look at another
ad here on facebook and this one's by
blue apron
and so of all the tips we've talked
about this particular ad takes into
account a lot of them okay so this is
again
they're using multiple images in this ad
here
so again what they're doing promotion
they're offering up a 30
off promotion here and what they're
asking you to do is sign up to get that
30 off so you could see the call to
action
we already mentioned that on one of our
tips the call to action
matches the ad so they're asking to sign
up they're using really good imagery
here
and they're supporting that with you
know some good copy and text
so this is what makes this ad so good i
mean who doesn't like
good looking food or tasty food and
healthy food
okay so they're definitely taking
advantage of the imagery
with a promotion and with a good call to
action and so
remember we want to a b test so blue
apron
is likely testing this ad so what they
could do with this
is test different imagery or they could
test a different promotion so there's a
lot they can do here on the a b testing
side
so for me if i were to test this yeah i
would probably be testing the imagery
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so
ideally there's a lot to do here from
the a b test standpoint
and the way they've structured this ad
it makes it very easy to test
so that's what makes this ad really good
is shows good imagery
has a good promotion and aligns the cta
tip number
11 so we want to place the product
in the right hand of your creative so
the right
side should contain our product imagery
so why is that why because there's been
a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation
and that states that depending on where
a product is placed
users would react differently to it and
so the study found that
users tend to react more positively when
the product is placed on the right side
of the ad creative so here you can see
countdown to black friday
this is an amazon related ad and you can
see the product
is basically a letterbox which is placed
on the right side so
it's a black friday ad they didn't place
the image on the left side they placed
on the right side
because people tend to react positively
when the
product image is on the right side so
keep that in mind when you're placing
your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12
don't use images that have more than 20
text okay so you want to use images that
are clean remember that blue apron image
we looked at
and that was a very clean image of food
no text overlaying the image
so we want to try and stay away from
images that have
text on the overlay okay so there's no
limit to how much text you can add to
your creative
but your facebook and myself recommend
hey the lesser text you have
the more likely it is for your ad to
have its desired impact
meaning somebody's gonna click on that
ad okay so keep that in mind let the
image do the talking for you you don't
necessarily need to
overwhelm the image with words or
messages
tip number 13 so we want to use an ad
creative that's attention grabbing
and is relevant for your business so
again going back to that blue
apron ad hey who doesn't like good
looking food
good looking healthy food green food
well
switching gears we're looking at a nike
ad who doesn't like a good
looking shoe here this is a good running
shoe and nike
is definitely taking advantage of the
opportunity to place
the shoe against a nice looking
background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mauve looking color
the shoe on the right on a nice red
background to kind of really
play into the color of the shoe and so
that's attention grabbing
so the colors kind of match and go with
one another
and it tends to grab your attention so
nike's doing a good job here of just not
showing an image of a shoe really what
they're doing is put the shoe as the
central focal point and supporting that
with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe
so they're making it as
attention-grabbing as possible here
so nike's done a good job with this ad
you know me
personally i'm not the biggest nike fan
when it comes to shoes
but hey this ad definitely grabbed my
attention because now i could see
you know this shoe is really popping to
me we don't want to use
clip art in your ad creative okay and
don't use
low resolution pixelated images as well
we want to use high quality imagery
so and use images that are well lit you
know natural lighting always tends to
work well as
as well so when you're doing a placement
for product
whether that be food or shoe you can see
here
in this plated example they're putting
it on the right image they're putting it
in a natural environment
on a table on a plate with some paper
next to it
you know and then you could see the one
on the left it's of a person holding a
box
with the image of plated on it and so to
me that's not stock imagery or clip
art you know that's an actual person
holding the product
so it's real life you want to make it as
real life as possible
and as clear and quality as possible so
when you create
attention grabbing ads you show images
of people
benefiting from your product instead of
just having the product itself so
that's always a good idea in the case of
coca-cola
you know these people are enjoying their
bottle of coca-cola
well going back to the nike ad you know
they could have had
a person wearing that shoe or you know
running with that shoe that could have
been an alternative for them as well
so the whole idea is just make sure your
ads are attention
getting and they grab your attention and
if you're gonna use people
make sure the person is enjoying it just
like on the previous
image the person holding the box we
could see she's got a smile on her face
and she
is enjoying holding that box so to me
you want to use people with the images
to the best
of your ability and that means use that
person who's enjoying it so that's
really going to put the product
in the forefront okay tip 14 don't
hesitate to experiment with your
advertisements creative or its copy okay
so what do we mean by that
really we want to be refreshing our text
we want to be refreshing our images
okay so if you're going to place an ad
on facebook
don't let that be the only ad okay if
you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image
from time to time especially if a lot of
people have seen that ad
so if you're using reach as your
objective
and you're trying to reach as many
people as possible just keep in mind
that
if that ad is reaching the same people
over and over again it's going to get
stale
and you want to be able to update that
ad so feel free to change out the
imagery
changing out the text is just as easy
okay so
feel free to play around with the text
even you're not doing a b
testing you can always change out the
text just to see
hey if changing out the text actually
gets you better engagement or
meet your goals tip 15 plan your
campaigns for the holiday season okay
so can't state this enough you know
towards
you know october november december there
tends to be a lot of holidays
you know across multiple religions okay
so it's really the time of year
where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode
so advertisers are really pushing ads
that time of year
especially christmas you know and people
are accepting of that because they're
used to it
so you want to be able to plan
accordingly so
if you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience
if you're aligning your ad with that
time of year
so during christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping
so it's a time of year where you can
really really really take advantage of
increasing your sales increasing your
conversions so you want to plan
accordingly
and so if you're planning you know
months in advance you don't have to do a
full year
but you know for me if i'm thinking i'm
going to do a lot of advertising during
the holiday season
i'm probably going to go out maybe once
summer ends
probably august beginning of september
beginning of september
seasons change a little i might start
thinking about the holiday season and
when you can plan appropriately
you can come out with really good ads
you can think about what you want to say
and so in this case you know target this
particular ad is really promoting black
friday so black friday
is the day after thanksgiving in the
united states
and so here they're letting you know
black friday's here
and there's deals to be had so planning
in advance gives you an opportunity to
really
really tweak your messaging and come up
with some good creative ideas so let's
take another
break and let's look at another good
looking ad this example we're going to
look at dell
okay so dell i've seen their ads all
over facebook
they do a lot of different advertising
types between videos
carousels and this is a single image ad
they're really trying to do is get you
over to the storefront so you can buy
one of these good looking
you know dell computers okay so you know
here
again they're promoting their latest
computer the dell inspirion 3000 series
all in one desktop so
to them anytime they create a new
product they're going to go ahead and
put out a new ad
for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a different
twist on it
if you notice the ad itself is just the
image of the product
there's really no promotion here they're
letting the product
image speak for itself they're really
showing you hey
look how good this computer looks you
know this is our new model
and you know we got to shop now ctas if
you're interested go ahead and click on
that shop now so they're really
putting the effort into the image itself
you know they're not offering any
promotion you know no discounts
you know what you see is what you get
with the image and you click on it
you're going to go right to their
storefront
so dell does a good job of really you
know cranking out their new products
whenever they go to market
so tip 16 shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so
retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website
somebody's even purchased from you
before you have the opportunity to reach
back out to that person
so how often you reach out to that
person or how long
between their initial engagement and
when you retarget them
really does depend on what it is you're
selling so if you're selling a pair of
shoes
if you're nike then chances are
somebody's looking for a pair of shoes
it's not going to be a long purchase
window meaning they're not going to wait
two three months so if i'm nike and
somebody's seen my ad
i'm probably going to target that person
in a short period of time
for retargeting so it really depends on
your product but you don't want to wait
too long
between the time they've been initially
engaged and the time you retarget so
really depends on your product
you know again if you're selling
merchandise you know retail
it's probably going to be a smaller time
frame if you're dell computers
you know that's a bigger purchase
somebody's going to take their time
so you know you want to target people
you know for their dell computer
probably
you know over a longer period of time
okay so
just keep the product in mind you don't
want to wait too long you don't want to
keep it too short
so you want to find that nice balance of
when you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17
keep altering the hook of your ad copy
what do we mean by altering the hook
so here you can see a couple of
different options option one
you know we're talking about hey if
you're interested in getting some
dmca certification you know this is what
you need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey
to get your dmc ca certification so
you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody
is really what we're after here on tip
number 17.
you have an ad especially the text
remember
we always want to refresh that copy but
if you're testing it
try different hooks try different ways
to talk to people okay it always works
well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be
to create multiple ads with different
hooks and see what performs best
so this is an option for a b testing
okay you have an option to add messaging
go ahead and talk one way
in one option and then you know tweak
that messaging
tweak that hook a bit in option b and
see what resonates with people so that's
a good option for a b testing is always
you know look at the way you're going to
try and
you know get somebody to convert tip
number 18
okay respond to lead ad responses as
soon
as possible so remember one of your ad
formats
is a lead ad okay so if you have a lead
ad basically what you're asking somebody
to do is add their name
their phone number and their email if
you get that information don't sit on it
react to it just like the messaging the
facebook messenger
how it's almost instantaneous think of
the lead ads the same way okay
you have somebody who's engaging with
your ad
by providing information you don't want
to sit on it you want to respond as soon
as possible
in fact you know when you do engage that
person let them know you're available on
facebook messenger so
they can actually then reach out to you
via facebook messenger just to expedite
the communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue
interacting with you so there's no real
good rule of thumb here
except for do it as soon as possible
okay
tip number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements
so what do we mean by that well in this
example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so
by putting this into your ad copy we're
hoping your prospects are more inclined
to buy your product
due to that fear that they're not going
to be one of the first 100
registrations okay so it allows you to
really
put some sense of urgency in the ad to
get somebody to react
so that's what we mean by you know
scarcity okay so
by doing so it could affect the
long-term
credibility you know we don't want to
come across as fear-mongering by any
means but
hey if your promotion is the first 100
registrations get free access
then why not you know go ahead and put
it in there some other examples could be
you know only three days left to
register or
first 50 get 50 off or
you know hurry now there's only two days
left so there's other language you can
put to play around with the language
but if you only have certain slots
available
or certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy
to get people to react and so that's the
whole idea
behind you know the scarcity is you want
to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevance scores so
your ads do get scored so the score
ranges from 1 to 10 okay so what that
score does
is it's an indicator to signify the
quality and engagement levels so
you know if your score is between 1 and
6
then the ad isn't reaching the relevant
audience and your audience isn't
reacting to it
however if your relevance score is
between
seven and ten then your ads are reaching
the appropriate audience and you're
getting a lot of interaction
so keep an eye on that you know the
lower the number that means hey
we're not get our ads not getting to the
right audience and if it's not getting
to the right audience our audience isn't
going to react to it so
it all starts with making sure you're
reaching your audience with your ad
when your ad is reaching your audience
and you're doing a b
testing your audience is gonna react to
one of those two ads so
that's always gonna help your relevance
score so keep an eye
on that relevant score okay so let's
take another break
here and let's take a look at an ad here
by blue bottle coffee okay so i'm a big
coffee drinker myself
i frequent blue bottle in san francisco
a lot
and so here this is a nice image a nice
close-up
image of coffee and i really like this
notice
there's really no call to action here
okay so
they're putting their website url the
domain bluebottlecoffee.com
they're saying hey we source great
coffees we roast them to perfection
and get them to you fresh so i can vouch
for that
really putting their brand out there
okay so this is more of a brand
awareness type ad that's their objective
their objective is
if you're going to drink coffee at some
other location or with some other brand
hey take a look at ours you know we got
good coffee too
we roast them pretty good and and we
make sure that you get them fresh
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to introduce their brand to you
so
this is a good example of a brand
awareness ad
single image ad they're definitely
making use of the added
the image itself you know with a nice
close-up shot
of that roasted coffee so that's what
makes this ad so special
brand awareness you know the image is
telling us
hey this coffee looks pretty pretty good
it looks nice and roasted
it looks pretty fresh and maybe i'll
give blue bottle
coffee a try so that's why they're
putting their domain there okay so it's
a good brand awareness ad
and the hope is to convert some people
over to
their brand okay so tip number 21
include emojis in your ad copy okay so
emojis
we know are popular you use them in text
use them on social media
i mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays
that you could pick and choose from they
are really specific
and so here you can see in the case of
simply learn hey
if you're taking a digital marketing
course for simply learn it doesn't hurt
to have some emojis support that
that message so you always get the
thumbs up to get emoji
you know the image of the graduation and
that's a good emoji
so you know you always want to align you
know really
fun relevant emojis with your messaging
it kind of just
helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with emojis
and so it doesn't hurt to add those
emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good
way to get your ad to stick out tip
number 22
use utm parameters to your ad which can
feed into your google analytics account
and provide tracking information so i
can't stress this enough if you're using
google analytics to track your campaigns
then you
want to use utm parameters so what do we
mean by utm parameters well let me show
you an example so
all you need to do is type in utm
tracking
or url builder in google and then you're
going to actually
get to this page here so what this does
this is a tool to help you create utm
tracking
so if we're simply learn and we want to
advertise and drive the audience to a
specific page in this case
artificial intelligence masters program
page so this is going to be the url
but we want to append that url with
some utm tracking parameters our
campaign source parameter
we're going to put facebook because
that's the source that we're advertising
the medium in which we're driving that
traffic to the page
from facebook is cpc which stands for
cost per click and then
we're just going to put campaign name ai
engineer to identify
what it is that campaign is related to
so notice that
the only required parameter is campaign
source in this case we're going to put
facebook
but we can also use campaign content if
we want to differentiate the different
ads that we have
so you can use campaign content
parameter as well you don't have to
the only required parameters campaign
source
my recommendation go all lowercase
okay and then when you're done you have
a url
that you can use in your advertising so
when somebody actually goes to that url
notice the url
includes the utm tracking and then
analytics is going to be able to pick
up that campaign from where facebook the
medium is going to be cpc
and the campaign in this case is going
to be ai engineer and that's what you're
going to look for
in google analytics so it helps you
track your ads
more closely because if you don't use
utm tracking for example on facebook
then analytics might you know interpret
that traffic
coming from that ad as you know organic
social so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what utm
tracking is you want to use it
for all your facebook advertising okay
so it really
helps you you know in analytics identify
how your campaign's performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign
converting for you so if you're trying
to get somebody to sign up for a class
then analytics is going to help us
measure those conversions but with utm
tracking we can bridge the gap between
how many people facebook delivered or
drove to our site from the ad
and how many of those people actually
converted so ut and parameters
help bridge that gap tip 23 use
exclusion marketing to improve your
facebook return on investment by not
including people who have already taken
the action desired by you okay
so this is a very key feature here
so if we've already advertised and
people
have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed
they have subscribed then we don't want
to target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to
you know target people that we're really
after so
if you know somebody's looked at our ad
and did not
convert or did not go to our website or
to not download something
or whatever it is we wanted them to do
then those are the people we
wanted to focus in on okay so in this
case exclusion marketing we're going to
exclude people
who have subscribed in this case we're
going to retarget people
meaning advertise again to people who
have not subscribed
so that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting
so that way you're not hitting the same
people over again
and that's only going to lead to poor
performance
tip 24 track the right metrics
for your business so keep your eye on
important metrics what are those metrics
you know those are going to be kpis kpis
are key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis
are related to business goals so track
the right
metrics for your business what are the
right metrics for your business
more than likely it's going to be
conversions or conversion rate but
you could be running a brand awareness
campaign just like blue bottle
coffee did and so if you're running a
brand awareness campaign then maybe
your kpi or metric is going to be a
click
okay or click-through rate how many
people are actually reacting to our ad
okay so you always want to align the
right metric with your business okay
it's just very
important that you're measuring against
the right metric
if you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of
how you judge the campaign performance
another
set of metrics could be reach and
frequency so reach and frequency
allow us to measure how many people saw
the ad and
post engagement can determine how many
users are reacting to your ads
cpc helps us determine the cost
effectiveness
or how much we're paying for every click
you could see that information
in your facebook ad manager for example
if i go to facebook's
ads manager here i'm looking at some
some ads that we're running
here what can i see i can see my reach
how many people i'm actually reaching
the frequency in which they're seeing my
ad notice i can see my relevancy score
i can also see my cost per result i can
see the total clicks
so i have a whole set of metrics
available to me
really what i want to do is pick and
choose the metrics that are most
important to the ad i'm running okay so
if it's reach am i reaching the full
amount of people
possible if i'm running a brand
awareness campaign or
it could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of facebook's
location tracking tool
for your advertisements so facebook
allows us to advertise
up to 25 countries with different states
provinces
cities districts and zip codes so we can
really hone in
location wise on where we want to target
so facebook allows us to do that so
basically it could be somebody in a
particular area
or people who have been recently been
there or traveling to that location or
actually lived there
so really could hone in on a specific
location
based on certain set of criteria so with
this you could take your marketing to
the next level by approaching your
competitors
customers by offering them better
discounts so that's the whole idea
targeting your advertising on a specific
location
and then knowing that your competitors
are there you can really
put out some really good ads with some
really good offers
to really convert some of those people
in that audience
okay let's take a look at another ad
okay
so grammarly this is an ad that they've
put out there and again you notice
there's no real true call to action
associated with the single image ad
here it's all about messaging here
they're saying hey
download it free today okay and so
it's a browser extension that they're
promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify
with this particular brand that offers a
specific product so
they do have a promotion in there it's
brand awareness hey
your life is about to change i mean the
messaging is pretty
you know matter of fact they're trying
to get you to hey
i need this in my browser as an
extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here
okay so with grammarly you know if
you're in gmail you're in word you're in
outlook they got you covered
by using their browser expansion it's
free and
by using it it's going to make your life
a lot easier so for me the ad
works from a messaging standpoint not
really big on the imagery
but it's really about this is who we are
and
we can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis
on the messaging so for me anytime
somebody says my life's about to change
they've got my attention now let's get
started
first off let's have a look at an
introduction to facebook
facebook was first launched in february
2004
and was initially known as the facebook
in 2005 it removed thee from its name
and has now become the facebook we all
know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media
and social networking service next
let's have a look at instagram it was
launched in 2010
for ios and then in 2012 for android
by kevin systrom and mike krieger
instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
platforms in the world
in april 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash and stock
now let's compare some stats between
facebook and instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats
first off facebook like i mentioned
earlier
facebook is the largest social media
platform in the world
reaching almost 60.6 of the internet
it has 2.5 billion monthly active users
and approximately 1.6 billion active
users
in fact as of jan 2020 the us has
approximately 190 million
and india has approximately 280 million
facebook users
an indication of a market that's still
ripe for the picking
now let's have a look at instagram
instagram
although having released significantly
later earns its title of the fastest
growing social media platform
with 1 billion monthly active users and
500 million daily users
in the united states there are
approximately 120 million
and india has close to 88 million
instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic age group of the user base
first off facebook although there's a
general opinion among the younger
population that facebook isn't hip or
isn't used all that much anymore this
statistic has something different to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
facebook users
are between the ages of 25 and 34.
for instagram it's no surprise that 71
of the user base
are under the age of 35. next
let's compare the usage time of both
these platforms
let's take facebook first in the united
states
users spend approximately one hour on
facebook every day
in india users spend an average of three
hours a day on facebook
shockingly high numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the united states
users spend 23 minutes on average on
instagram
in india users spend approximately 45
minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for facebook eighty-six percent of
marketers
use it for advertising instagram is used
by 71 percent of businesses
for their marketing requirements now
let's have a look at some industries
that can work
well on both these platforms if you do
belong to any of these industries
if you're not taking advantage of these
platforms you're missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media
e-commerce automobile
and package goods next time you're on
facebook
take a closer look at your feed there's
a good chance you'll see most of these
industries post
on it next up instagram
we have industries like fashion
athleisure
cosmetics automobiles and food and
beverages
i can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find
all these industries advertising on
instagram
now let's take a closer look at how
facebook can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an
online presence for your organization
for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch
a webinar a live broadcast a new store
opening
anything whatever it is it can go on
your facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page
you get greater visibility letting
people know about the products
and services that you offer you can
offer customer service as well
in fact according to american express 90
of users use customer service as a
deciding factor
for whether or not they continue to do
business with an organization
so customer service is pretty important
like i mentioned earlier
your business page provides a place
where you can offer your followers
offers and other advantages and finally
the page lets you build a community a
highly targeted community
that has a higher possibility of buying
your products and services
next we have facebook groups with
facebook groups you can build a
community
of like individuals some of the
advantages that come with this are
it provides a highly targeted audience i
mentioned earlier that business pages
provide you with a highly targeted
audience
groups take that to the next level it
enables everyone to learn from one
another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members
know things that others don't your group
will enable them to communicate with
each other
and learn these new things you also get
honest feedback
your customers who are also likely part
of the group will be able to give
their feedback on how they like your
product and perhaps
even give you tips on how to improve now
since your group is filled with a
community
that's highly interested in your brand
you can also increase engagement in an
organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next facebook has events with facebook
events your
organization will be able to mobilize
your brand
and enable online consumer marketing
basically meaning that you have a
platform
for letting people know about important
announcements not to mention there's
also the opportunity to get some free
advertising done
events also help you increase brand
awareness
most people get to know about your brand
by attending the event
or just seeing the promotion for it now
let's have a look at facebook stories
for groups and pages
a feature that is available for both
groups and pages it provides you the
ability
to appropriately represent your brand or
business
directly from your mobile device or
desktop
now some of its advantages are that it
helps you engage with your audience
with stuff other than the usuals like
articles videos and other similar posts
this way you can also vary the kind of
content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers
stories help your brand show that you're
genuinely interested in your audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency
next facebook has facebook messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience
at a personal level in the last few
years
messenger has proved itself to be a
great marketing tool
it helps acquire more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them
and by directly interacting with them
through messenger
their loyalty towards you is certainly
said to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction
and even if a customer doesn't give you
a transaction
at least you're increasing your brand
awareness
then we have facebook live facebook live
gives you a platform
to interact with your audience in real
time it can be used to diversify your
content
providing your audience with something
different from what they've received
from your brand initially
live can also be used to show what
happens behind the scenes in your
organization
further helping humanize your brand and
finally you can also provide
instant questions and answers to your
audience increasing engagement with them
next we have the facebook shop the
facebook shop is a business page
tab application that enables your
customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store
it also has the following advantages
firstly you can use the shop
to drive new sales you can give the
customers who are on the fence about
your product
a small push by engaging them and how
can you do that
with deals and promotions you can also
reward advocates of your brand with
special benefits to be availed from your
store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition
now let's have a look at facebook ads
facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on facebook
now some of the advantages of facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience
and it provides you with greater reach
while making you spend lesser amounts of
money
it also helps you re-advertise or
re-target
your products to an existing audience
and finally
it helps increase revenue sales and
leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about facebook ads you can check out our
facebook ads video
i'll add it in the live chat so you can
check it out if you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature facebook offers to help you with
marketing
facebook insights i'm sure all of you
have heard about google analytics
let's just say this is facebook's
version of that
with insights you get information that
can help you refine your brand strategy
by tracking and measuring results it can
help you determine reach and engagement
actions people who are viewing your
posts when your fans are online
the type of posts that are working for
you and much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
facebook helps you with marketing
now let's move on to instagram first off
we have instagram business accounts
instagram business accounts enable
brands
to be recognized as businesses now it
also has the following benefits to offer
it's only with a business account that
you can get instagram insights
we'll talk about insights in a little
more detail in a little bit
you can also add a contact button on
your profile
enabling users to connect with you
directly
you can also specify what kind of
service you offer
by adding what industry you belong to in
your bio
and finally you also have the ability to
add links to your instagram stories
now i'm sure you've all seen the see
more option in your stories
so now you know how that shows up now if
you guys are interested in finding out
how you can increase followers on
instagram
you can check out our video on the same
topic of the same name
i'll add the link in the live chat next
let's talk about instagram stories
with instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement
build brand awareness and to drive sales
you can also use stories to provide
recent updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow their audience
and can enable them to engage with their
audience regularly
with stories you can also drive traffic
to other websites
like your company's website it can also
help diversify your content
setting it apart from the usual videos
and photos next up let's talk about
instagram dms
or direct messages dms help you grow
your business
by interacting with customers at a
personal level
it can also help build connections with
your users by building a personal
connection with your followers their
loyalty towards your brand is improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry
and as an extension of the last few
points this leads to easier lead
generation
and increase sales next up we have igtv
now ittv is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently
it enables your brand to get closer to
its audience
and enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include greater
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improved engagement and greater chances
of conversions
finally it also helps build a community
of a highly targeted audience
next we have instagram live instagram
live enables you to communicate with
your audience
in real time further improving your
discoverability
and strengthening your connection with
the audience
moreover it provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on
live stream and finally it helps you
interact with your
audience in real time this helps further
humanize your brand
next we have instagram ads instagram ads
provides you with control over
advertisements
you decide how they appear and who sees
them like facebook instagram has a
number of different ad types to offer
they are photo ads video ads carousel
ads
slideshow ads and stories ads
next up instagram offers an instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly
from an image showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
instagram shop
is that it provides easy product
discoverability
and since it provides visual marketing
it also leads to more sales
and finally instagram insights
instagram's answer to facebook insights
and google analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
impressions and reach
best and worst performing content
profile visits
website clicks and much more and with
that we have come to an end of this
facebook ads
full course video for 2021 i hope it was
informative and interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team of experts
will be happy to solve all your queries
thank you for watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here